yes so I have a nonprofit organization  called hoops two of I work with Chris  long who runs water boys we basically  build clean water wells and East Africa  and Tanzania so every summer I go over  there I raise money through the season I  have four other guys in the NBA that are  helping me raise money on different  teams and I'm trying to just raise as  much money as I can to build more wells  and then I go visit the people in Africa  and see sort of the impact it has how  much did the calls for well $45,000  I'll give you 45 thousands there we go  five thousand right now  I appreciated the truck will make it  yeah we put the names if you if you give  enough money for a while we put your  name and then net that well his name but  it's done well just put one here called  cheapskate in Kenya and Ghana you got  you got four to five thousand I wonder  will you take a two nothing lead you got  a new well and